the [ __ ] is this
[Music]
it looks like robbief the coloring is
kind of off like it's a little bit
darker than I'd expect it looks like
someone took tuna like smashed it up and
then just like laid it across rice I
don't see how you can make tuna vegan so
I don't trust it who am i nervous okay
hmm
what that is weird oh my god this is
vegan that's actually really good
Oh flavorless I don't know if it tastes
like tuna but it's good what is this
this tomatoes oh my what
Wow what that makes sense it kind of
looks like tomato skin like inside out
it has all the flavors but you have none
of the texture I really like that it
doesn't taste like tuna at all though
it's more like sun-dried tomato yeah
once I know that it's a tomato I can't
not taste tomato that makes sense it did
taste really tart and fruity like a
tomato exact slide over here good close
to my mic try this
Zacks a big sushi boy like there's a lot
of vegan food that is surprisingly crazy
good and like it's just expensive or
hard to find but if you told me that I
could eat this every day I'd be like
yeah I'm fine with that it doesn't look
good to me
hmmm vegans and vegetarians still like
to eat things that taste good doesn't
matter that it looks like me it just
matters that it's not I'm so happy that
there's a good legit sushi alternative
for vegan people because that doesn't
really exist and so now
[Music]